you love to ride a motorcycle I know
that about you and and one of the things
that occurred to me about that is what
what few times what the hell was that oh
you just he put your foot up I thought a
trap door was open I always think
they're gonna get a new host and pull
the after all these years anyway it
happens
I was curious the times that I've been
on a motorcycle what I've really loved
about it there's a lot of things I think
about it but I like the anonymity of it
exactly you put on a helmet and you're
just a guy in a helmet yeah yeah you're
just a guy on a bike so half an hour on
a motorcycle for me is amazing in terms
of just being you know invisible and as
an actor you can look at people and I
serve people yeah and they're not
staring back and going like oh it's
Lawrence there's nothing really stopping
you from wearing a motorcycle helmet to
a restaurant
who is that guy he's really you guys are
for each bite you you're on blackish
yeah which is a terrific show thank you
it must be nice you are in addition to
having had this you know incredible
acting career and having the gravitas of
being Laurence Fishburne you you sort of
get to be the paternal figure almost on
them yeah I'm in the grandpa chair and
the grandpa chair is really comfortable
yeah yeah that's nice you got it's nice
nothing2prove just have fun just have
fun I get to say the [ __ ] that I know
that I've known for a while and nobody
can argue with me now because I'm argue
I'm old I'm like that's right trying to
intimidate me you can't see very well
it's great it's great there's a there's
a special Christmas episode through
specific to Morrow is that right Mauro
night yeah
lot of things we have a clip here the
front beat I think this is the a clip
from the blackish Christmas episode
tomorrow night let's take a look then
they opened their treasures and
presented him with gifts of gold
frankincense and myrrh
did you guys hear that huh your what up
on the roof if it's up on the roof it
can only mean one thing
[Applause]
Christmas that no one forgets I have a
sack full of presents you ride
what's that you order if you ride you
yeah so we should get some Santa Claus
suits and some hats and get a couple of
Harley's and ride on Christmas Day I'll
just call my wife and say we're not
going to Seattle to see her parents
oh no she would definitely let me do it
she would definitely help me fantastic
did you ever done that if you ever loved
what I remember was one of the greatest
moments I've had living here in Los
Angeles is one day Christmas morning I'd
drove down the Sunset Boulevard and
there were five dudes five older dudes
wearing Santa Claus suits riding harleys
down Sunset Strip I was like the best
that's great it made you believe all
over all over again yeah all right the
Christmas episode of blackish airs at
9:30 tomorrow night on ABC and you can
download the watch ABC app now to catch
up on the entire season you can also see
Lawrence on Broadway in American Buffalo
this is some fantastic yessum who are
you doing it with myself Sam Rockwell a
young actor named Aaron Chris are gonna
be doing American Buffalo in New York
Knicks that's fantastic yeah it's gonna
be a minute and that is starting when
does it start it starts in we starts in
March yeah previews in March mid March
are you guys into it already now no we
start rehearsing in late February you
don't have much time that's gonna be an
amazing production I look forward to
that Laurence Fishburne so cool to have
you here
[Applause]